c'était le 14 mai les 41 hommes de
patrick bruel aux ennemis tout beau tout
rose amis qui étaient là
alors patrick avec le café des délices
et elie vous renouez avec vous avec vos
origines une certaine façon ce que c'est
la première fois vous chanter des
chansons qui qui concerne notre origine
un objet de mes athlètes scène votre
mère était institutrice vous avez un an
lorsque votre père quitte le domicile
conjugal en 1960 en 62 l'été 62 c'est le
retour en france
et finalement vous dites comme on
n'avait rien on n'a rien eu a abandonné
d'une certaine façon parce que votre
grand père était secrétaire de mairie à
tlemcen et finalement ça vous a pas
tellement coûter de partir apparemment
tentation à l'âge de 3 ans ça coûte pas
là votre famille non plus
affectivement certainement si moyens
sûrs qu'ils quittent un pays dans lequel
la plupart étaient était né dans
lesquelles ils ont vécu ces deux le
déracinement l'arrivée en métropole je
crois que ça n'a pas été facile pour
beaucoup de gens il ya des gens qui ont
essayé bien très important que les gens
qui n'ont laissé qui ont laissé autre
chose puisque effectivement donc
s'installer avec votre mère argenteuil
alors le départ de votre père et puis
finalement le fait de vous retrouver
tous les deux comme ça à argenteuil ça
vous rapproche encore death d'une
certaine façon
alors c'était de la psychanalyse de
bistrot mais est ce que c'est pour ça
qu'à 40 ans j'ai toujours tout seul
vous cherchez encore la femme de vote du
nouveau quartier vous dit que c'est tout
seul
c'est pas mariée à parce que si on n'est
pas marié on est tout seul on vous
connaît pas d' aventure durable
réécoutez peut-être que la discrétion
est à bord c'est un scoop alors énorme
vous auriez trouvé quelqu'un venu
bottemer non mais ça c'est la
psychanalyse même pas de comptoir ça
c'est avant le comtois n'ont pour piano
sérieux blague à part vous avez eu peur
mais marié notre coupe finisse comme
celui de beaux parents non j'ai pas eu
peur
il est pro ou les probable puisque
voulait faire de la psychanalyse qui a
certes un schéma de bistrot non là on
est on va monter un peu plus il ya des
choix qu'on a peut-être pas envie de
reproduire c'est donc à une peur qui
peut s'installer mais enfin mais c'est
pas totalement c'est pas lié uniquement
la peur n'ont jamais sur lesquels
pointent surtout lié c'est l'iliade et à
des événements à des rencontres et allah
et à une évidence on rencontre quelqu'un
une évidence si on n'a pas cette
évidence
on attend et puis c'est vrai qu'avec la
vie la vie qu'on mène lé les
sollicitations
et c'est énorme on est on est pas en
voyage beaucoup on bouge beaucoup on est
dans le restaurant de rester fixe
ensuite vous n'êtes pas le sentiment
d'être passé à côté de quelqu'un
quelqu'un vous dit maintenant avec le
recul finalement elle j'aurais peut-être
dû non non la première peut-être
patricia ouais bah brésilienne ouais ça
lui était rejointe à new york en 79 oui
bah aujourd'hui j'aurais peut-être un
jour voilà où j'en étais d'un enfant
aujourd'hui qui serait un renfort de
l'équipe du brésil s'était battu la
france en finale
tous les gars vous avez rencontré
presgurvic sommes alors à new york
cherchait un piano et vous aviez une
copine qui avait un piège à c est louis
pasquet t elle avait dû des sous alors
elle avait vu sa passe à mr oui je pense
pas qu'elle voulait un fils à mon fils
richet est plaint de ce que voulait
quelque chose d'autre chose pour sa
fille on vous avait dit c'est vrai que
vrai qu'à ma virée salama tamer navire
est la mer un bon alors vous avez des
goûts dit vous êtes sport dans la
séduction et mais après ça dure pas très
longtemps que j'ai dit nos tragédies
suis facile à séduire je pas facile à
garder
ouais c'est ça ouais maintenant c'est
réglé donc on peut hein on peut ce
salaire salaire est bien partie live
pas à tort images aux mots
je me demande de vous inviter dit à mes
parents ma fille rosa on va revenir aux
10 donc c'est un énorme succès comme on
vient de le dire maintenant quand vous
repensez à la bruel magna vous y pensez
comment pour vous c'est c'est douloureux
ou c'est non c'est à dire que c'est
difficile à cerner cette histoire parce
qu'entre le entre la relation médiatique
qui a eu avec avec ça et et ce qui s'est
passé fondamentalement avec le public
il ya toujours un décalage la
description faite par les médias et ce
qui se dit ce que je vivais dans les
salles étaient été décalé faut dire que
les médias parler d'hystérie
moi je voyais de l'enthousiaste je
voyais la ferveur c'était c'était
peut-être tout devenait très réducteur
elle même registre le zénith c'était pas
patrick honohan 10 heures les gens
étaient et patrick pendant des heures le
patrick avec 5 imerys qui me rend fou et
qui hélas était terrifiant sage light
n'est pas dans les salles
oui je vais parler plus les gens qui me
chambrent un peu et puis se sont mués un
peu et en prédisant aussi donc oui mais
on a des nouvelles qui en 15 ans oui
c'est vrai que la majorité des compose
de public ont entre 25 et 30 ans mais
par exemple un épisode comme la la pizza
pino vous étiez là vous publiez pu
sortir vous êtes passés chez un coiffeur
ça ça par exemple c'est des souvenirs
douloureux pour vous mais non ça t'a
souvenirs amusants sur le moment mais ce
qui est douloureux c'est toute la
récupération qui en a eu qui a été fait
et tout ce qui a été dit derrière nous
on est tout simplement avec arcady à six
heures du soir parce qu'il a ses bureaux
à côté qu'on doit écouter une chanson et
finalement il me dit tiens on va boire
un coup dans cette pizzeria où on a
passé notre vie on est tout le temps là
on était plein on est aussi long du fort
au fond du trou qu'on n'a jamais été en
terrasse
il ya quelqu'un qui rentre et qui m'a vu
qu'ils avaient les copines qui l'a fait
une espèce de mouvement
nous on s'est marré et puis ensuite on a
essayé de se barrer mais là c'est
difficile et donc cette fois-ci ensuite
il ya eu près ce machin papaya des
champions dit qu'on avait monté le truc
ouais mais c'est vrai qu'à un moment le
la dimension sociologique de votre
carrière l'emporter soit dimension
artistique quand même non
je rejoue l'entendre dire non mais c'est
vrai mais c'est vrai bien sûr bon elle a
été utilisée a été étudié par des
psychanalystes
quant à l'époque lé peuvent notamment
catherine denis law et martin le rude
fléché que je salue ici alors eux ils
disent que il voit dans la brute
allemagne a une dimension sexuelle très
sérieusement hein ils disent que ça
permet aux adolescentes de s'abriter
d'une sexualité trop précoce c'est une
manière pour elle d'attendre et de tenir
le coup la belle manière c'était ça pour
eux si vous faites marrer mais s'adapte
l'amour qu'elle portait là l'amour que
les fans vous porte n'est pas moi c'est
l'amour que dès que des fans peuvent
porter à des artistes en général c'était
particulièrement oui non mais cette
saison c'est le cas pour voilà et donc
si vous étiez en fait comme un
paratonnerre c'est à dire qu'elle se
elle reportait sur bout et j'adore me
sentir utile même temps j'ai vachement
alors y'a un sociologue louis afrique
millions le prologue
oui le sociologue patrick millions il a
dit il faut que patrick bruel se marie
pour négocier habilement sa reconversion
est ce que je remarque c'est que vous
avez réussi votre carnation sans vous
marier mouais finalement comme quoi et
si ça recommence et aujourd'hui mais
quoi exactement ce à quoi il est
difficile à décrire parce que si c'est
dans les salles en ce moment aimer c'est
parmi eux marc seize prévenus à bordeaux
n'est pas venu à l'idée m'est venue
c'est assez incroyable mais à la fois
j'ai pas l'impression que ce soit
tellement différent mais c'est la
description qui en est faite est
différente et c'est là et c'est le
regard sur le personnel à des gens il y
en a plein qui sont en concert qui sont
qui sont enterrés les gens voient des
petites familles qui sont venus
plusieurs fois
voilà alors venez venez voilà c'est
mieux je suis sûr qu'on attend pour
caracas sur son visage
comment ça se passe comment alors est-ce
qu'à la même hystérie kaka dix ans les
gens sont beaucoup plus calme et bon en
fait c'est une rencontre entre amis on
se reconnaît on à l'impression de passer
une soirée entre amis et puis il ya une
ambiance formidable mais pas les moyens
du bord
non mais jamais il ya quelques hystérie
qui font boule de neige mais franchement
il n'ya jamais eu d'hystérie que les
vrais fans ne sont pas hystérique et
voilà merci beaucoup
mais vingt femmes ne sont pas hystérique
alors patrick bruel à une époque donc à
la grande époque de cette bruel manière
dont on vient de parler vous alliez à 7
sur 7 vous répondu à des questions
basques ont sérieuse sur sur des sujets
très grave et très sérieux donc pour
changer un peu
je vous ai fait une interview nul